[Music]
so let me start with like kind of a I
guess a process question but I used to
teach with Junot Diaz and I heard him
say one time that most of the writers he
knew they'd had some experience early in
life where they were you know shown that
that language is power and that that
kind of gets into your psyche and so for
you was there some early thing where you
were told that music was a power source
for you my parents when I was born we
lived in a trailer in a mobile home in
my grandparents yard and the only
childcare was that I would stay with my
grandparents and my parents were both
teenagers when I was born and you know
worked real hard didn't have a whole lot
of money but um my granddad would teach
me from really early on how to play and
Shirley started it probably six with a
mandolin because my hands were so small
and when I got older I figured out he
tried that with my dad too but my dad
never really took to it but every kid in
the family you know when you got a
certain age he'd try to teach you a
little bit of the mandolin because it's
such a easy instrument for a little kid
to play you know but I didn't I switched
over to guitar pretty quickly after that
but the experience with him I think I
owe any of the sanctity of music to that
you know because that was very like at
that time we were just spending time
together and it didn't occur to me that
it took you know most of his day to show
me how to play one chord I know and it
didn't until I knew what it was like to
teach somebody that kind of stuff you
know I realized that he really yeah a
huge part of it was bonding with me
another part of it was keeping me from
breaking things and you know keeping me
occupied and keeping my hands busy but
he would he would do this thing where
he'd make me play rhythm guitar for a
couple of hours on the big you know
dreadnought guitar that he had and he
would play a lead instrument like banjo
or fiddle and mandolin or something and
if I would put up with a couple hours of
playing rhythm guitar then he would put
the guitar in his lap and play blues
music was pocketknife and that was my
reward I felt like a reward it felt very
much like a reward because I was
immediately obsessed with the blues
immediately right
and the other stuff was fine and I liked
it and but that was you know so much
sudden that kind of drove him crazy
because that's all I ever wanted to hear
him talk over some other songs that he
were playing that you would play
together we did a lot of gospel you know
traditional country gospel music but he
also did you know Hank Williams songs he
liked the old humorists of the grand ole
opry string bean and Jimmy Dickens and
and you know songs about you know your
mother-in-law or something or he would
do I'm my own grandpa which I think was
probably I think Grandpa Jones probably
made him popular but I don't know who
wrote it but he you know he would do
those kind of bald headed into the broom
little Jimmy Dickens sleeping at the
foot of the bed and that was his sense
of humor but but there was always like
you know a gospel number blue eyes
crying in the rain he liked Willie
Nelson you know and and then in between
that there was something with a bit of a
message was that was there a moment when
you first wrote something to kick
somebody's ass that you can remember yes
I remember exactly when it happened I
wrote lyrics to I was in the jazz band
and in high school and we were playing
this like Duke Ellington you know
standard or something something that was
pretty simple and I wrote a set of
lyrics to it and I showed him to my
parents in the car and I was probably
you know 13 14 years old and I remember
my parents were amazed they're like you
just wrote that you just made that up
and you know and it was it was my
imitation of a blues lyric you know
which is laughable now was laughable
immediately after now but I also I made
the mistake of taking it with me to
baseball practice I remember taking a
changing out leaving this piece of paper
sitting with my things at baseball
practice and one of the other kids got a
hold of it
and they gave me Hale everybody the
baseball team laughs oh is this a poem
what are you doing I'm gonna point point
yeah yeah so I caught hell for that but
uh but yeah not now don't catch hell for
it no no so much yeah so so are you
comfortable talking about process like
how you actually do it as it is that a
meaningless question or does it I mean
no no I mean yeah I'm very I'm very
comfortable talking about it yeah I
should confess that I'm like a lifelong
[ __ ] songwriter and I had the aspiration
of writing one good one before I die so
it's just kind of like a tutorial so I'm
gonna try to pick your brain but when
you so when you're and these are kind of
basic questions but when you're writing
a song are you a kind of lyrics first
melody first I'm sure it's much more
like organic than that but give us an
example of how a song would come to you
and then how would how would you extend
that little idea into the full song if
that makes sense it's almost exactly
like I was reading a thing that you were
talking about in The Guardian I think
about about your process when you've
written a piece about you know how you
you know follow where the character goes
to follow when the story goes and it was
very very similar like it it struck me
as where my wife and I passed it back
and forth and talked about it a lot and
everything she's a songwriter also she's
also a poet and so so we talked about
that in the process a lot but I don't
always use Elise tart out knowing what
the point of this song is gonna be it's
it's you know I'll start out with a
phrase or with a melody usually the the
phrase that winds up getting repeated in
the chorus now this is you know the
majority of the time but it happens so
different and the structures of each
song are so different that that it's not
always like this but the majority of the
time I'll start repeating a phrase in my
head that comes with a melody you know
based on the the way the words can you
know my mind will find a melody that
goes with the with the rhythm of the
diction of a it's not to be too pedantic
but that I'm kind of curious about what
comes before that does that phrase or
the melody is that kind of a like a
spontaneous gift that the universe gives
you or for example might you
you know observe something and then
convert it into a phrase or I mean is
there some yeah where was the very very
first inspiration come from there's a
question I would never I would hate it
somebody yeah but I honest I understand
exactly what you mean though you know if
you train yourself and I know without
question that you you've done this same
thing but you train yourself to look in
the corners that everybody doesn't
always look in and you train yourself to
hear the conversations that most people
aren't paying any attention to and and
you get better at pulling little pieces
of those out you know and you know the
song on my newest album called
Cumberland Gap and it's and it started
many years ago the idea for this song
started when we were playing a place in
Whitesburg Kentucky and they had just
gone wet after not selling alcohol
forever and there was a coal miner that
was sitting on the sidewalk drinking a
beer he's covered and dust and he was
just staring at the beer and you know he
I could just see him thinking how am i
pot how's it possible that I can buy one
of these when I get off of work and it
took me years to get that to a song but
sometimes it's just immediate like
traveling alone there's a song on south
eastern called travelin alone and it
happened it's very literal sometimes
like I was sitting in an airport and you
know it's like man this sucks just
having to go from city to city by myself
and I'm tired traveling alone and then
all of a sudden oh oh there it is
there's one you know okay something is
striking about your songs is they're
very natural they're almost sort of
slightly heightened conversation and as
you're hearing them in real time you're
like yeah
yep and suddenly that moment where you
the listener is really joined to the
writer by this common experience but the
other part of it in addition to being
natural and organic and not sort of
styled up they're also really incredibly
poetic is understating it but the times
were I guess the way I would say they
seemed to hit they show evidence of a
lot of revision like in the same way
that a good piece of fiction is it looks
spontaneous and yet it looks totally
inevitable
but now we have the advantage of you
know spending four years just working
and working what does the revision
process look like in in songwriting
because I prefer exam I heard Willie
Nelson say wants to know you you write
it all at once or it's no good which I
don't know if that's true or not it may
be for Willie hood it's not for me you
know and it wasn't for Leonard Cohen
from what I understand you know and he
spent a lot of time on each individual
line and I do too you know trying to
figure out if there's a way that's more
comfortable you know from a performance
aspect because you know you think about
the message that you're delivering the
lyric you know the narrative or the you
know the the prose of it but then also
you have to deal with the puzzle of
fitting it into a space rhythmically in
the meter of it you know and making it
rhyme which can be for me I love having
to make it rhyme because that's the one
restriction I think that I enjoy working
in the most and that's one of the things
you know in listening to your songs
there's always that kind of the first
line will come and it's rich and then
there's a kind of a extra boost when the
second one not only rhymes in a
beautiful way but it escalates I'm
thinking about in children of children
that thing about I was riding on my
mother's hip she was taller than the
corn mm-hmm that's pretty amazing so I'm
happy at that point I could just turn
off but then this the follow-up all the
years I took from her just by being born
that that's sort of such a beautiful
escalation is is something like that you
know is the first line sitting around
for a long time or is it kind of a I'm
sure it's different all the time but it
is but there's like one I think one
solid sentiment that I'm trying to get
across or one image that I'm trying to
get across and it's very much like a
like a Chinese number puzzle or
something you know because you have to
you know you have to put this word in
this place and it's got a rhyme in a
certain way either because I don't like
really really wonky rhymes you know
really crazy I think it should seem
natural shouldn't seem like I had to
really try really hard to make those
words and what I'm doing is working with
one image that's created by the two
lines together that ROM and
and I will change the words that rhyme a
lot of times but if I change one I have
to change the other you know but the
images is usually staying the same
usually it's like okay what do I want to
say in these two lines and and you know
sometimes I'll start from the last word
and I'll work backwards you know and
I'll spend time with rhyming
dictionaries with you know--this or I
was whatever whatever I have you know
none of it's none of it's out of my all
right but it sounds it sounds like the
is it the case that when you get it you
know it yes yeah yes usually usually and
if I don't my wife will tell me if I
think I've got it and I don't my wife
will tell me hey you sure I was gonna
ask are you showing things to her in
process or is there a grand reveal where
something's done in me it started off as
a grand reveal but but then after a
while I figured out okay it's better
just to not say it's done until she says
it's a songwriter
oh yes she isn't she'd be so happy here
you said that but she has the printer in
her office I don't have the printer in
mom so when I finish finish a song I'll
print it out and he goes to her first
and and and then she'll look at it and
sometimes she just says this is this is
perfect and then but more often than not
there'll be questions ya know and she's
one of those that you know she's
diplomatic and in that she doesn't use a
red pen for Christ's sake Orange yeah
yeah some other color that's not red so
I immediately apply another age but um
also she she'll ask questions is this
you know the best way to say this or is
this exactly what you mean or she even
has sometimes if I'm writing a song that
has a whole lot of my own personal
experience and it just is this doesn't
seem like that's exactly what happened
you know that's that's the way the
reason writer in the end the the best
praise as when she just says yeah you
know oh yeah but but there are times
when the the wifely position allows one
to know the [ __ ] that's likely to
rise on the surface and then and all she
ever did was kind of lift when I run
okay I know I know page six I know it
yeah don't humiliate me too much you
know I'm contender yeah is there a
give me a little like mini-course in
what a good song is I mean and I mean
like your artists Assessor you know like
when you're listening something in your
having an honest first response and also
what are some symptoms of a like a bad
or a sort of mid-level song that does
that yeah yeah cliche is you know number
one on the list of bad things always
number one anything that's even a
situational cliche a cliche of subject
matter you know is just really really
hard and you know sometimes I'll
challenge myself to write you know like
a speed trap town is basically you know
it's a song about small-town life and
pickup trucks and football games and
things that could go horribly wrong and
a song with mishandled so that was a bit
of a challenge for me which I kinda saw
it as potentially
yeah the subject matter is definitely
cliche in country music you know but but
I think if you handle it right and you
pick the right details then you know in
writing in fiction but Syracuse we every
year would read about 700 manuscripts
for admissions and one of the things
that really put my nerves on edge is any
sense of overt agenda on the writers
part and especially if the if the writer
has the agenda agenda and then sticks to
it yeah as if the agenda is the thing
they were gonna lord over you a little
bit and I noticed like a speed trap town
I never even occurred to me that it's
the same material this country you know
kind of bad country until you said that
it feels like as is the case and a good
piece of fiction the writers intention
is moving around in search of the Afro
energy of the song goes in in the
meaning and the images but also in the
melody so you come through that one and
you think of the title you know yeah
that that's his be trapped town but it's
about it from such an interesting
variety of angles I guess I would say
yeah and I used to think that that was a
flaw in my songwriting that
didn't have an ultimate point sometimes
but then after I read enough and really
liked found out what I really liked as
far as details and narrative went then I
thought no that maybe that's maybe
that's a good thing that I and I don't
necessarily have a point to making every
one of these songs but I noticed as the
point is often much more complex and
ambiguous than any point one could
imagine at the outset right yeah and
that's the trick to I think is is you
know the trick in a title also you know
it's like if we were vampires seems like
it would be very very different from the
title even when we went in to record it
in the studio
Dave Cobb was producing the record kept
putting us off every time I would say if
that's the song called if we were
vampires he his idea of what that was
going to be with something very very
different from what it turned out
because if somebody said to to me a [ __ ]
songwriter that's the title I would work
it to death I'd there'd be five
different varieties of that but it
actually appears as once and this is
just one time and I liked that I liked
him I like a title with you know a lyric
that only happens one time I guess for
that reason because it doesn't pin you
down to anything as far as you know
agenda like you were saying what I'm
trying to get from myself to the
audience is very often just you know
life is many things well I think one
thing a listener feels with your music
is that you're as invested in the
mystery of it as they are you're not
you're not you're determining it and
then dump it all
definitely yeah exactly yeah and I've
read where you talked about that as far
as as as far as writing prose and
writing fiction goes to is is you know
you don't start out to write a song
about this and wind up writing a song
about this and have something beautiful
in the middle not really specific ways
that you can chase yourself off of that
because I know for me that it's it'll be
so much nicer if I could just decide to
write a story about X and then do it it
would be but my working life would be so
much less stressful but but part of the
you know craft of fiction for me is is
identifying when I start phoning it in
and then chasing myself off that are
there techniques and sorry I mean oh
yeah yeah sometimes you can use the
the musical composition of something to
take you in that direction or to prevent
you from going where you would normally
go on autopilot also you know will write
a song without a chorus you know I mean
if we were vampires doesn't have a
chorus there's a song I wrote called
Live Oak that's that's a a little bit of
an allegory and you know about this sort
of split in my personality and my
identity really when I got sober and and
you know the person who I left behind
and wondering about the validity of that
person and and you know but there's no
chorus there and then had I put a chorus
in that song I feel like it could have
gotten very you know very much like a
planned out I want to tell people what
what is that because I mean is that
because internally the conventionality
of the structure would let you go back
to the shore a little bit I mean other
totally yeah let's yeah let's you like
let's you get out of the water and rest
for a second and catch your breath and
you don't you don't need to catch your
breath right you know catching your
breath is a mistake it's like why waste
their time you know now if a chorus is
necessary and usually it is necessary
because there's a part of a song that
that you know no other type of writing
really has and there's that that part
where you want people to get energized
about singing you know a certain lyric
over and over which is really [ __ ]
weird if you ask me it's very unnatural
but it's also you know there's some part
of your brain that likes to repeat
things it's I can't tell you how many
hours I've spent my kitchen going you
thought God was an architect now you
know oh yeah like a pipe bomb ready to
blow and I just find myself doing what
am I saying that oh yeah it's in that
you know that had to be that chorus had
to be there and you know I changed it a
little bit at the end and sometimes you
do change things but like 24 frames that
song was one that started out very very
differently and intent from what it
became you know because it started out
about you know growing yourself into a
better person and about how little time
you have in which to do that you know
you have to recognize your own
opportunities for maturity like oh this
is you know this is the world having a
parenting moment for me right now and I
have to take advantage of it but it
became about you know grief and about
you know mourning a relationship in the
way that you mourned a death you know
and you know I think that was one of the
really good things about that song
because it's there's a way of being
vague without being they you know a way
of being very detailed and very specific
and still being you know vague in a way
that's really beautiful I think is there
at the end of us I mean is there a
moment where you say it's done I mean
there must be but does that feel like
because for in fiction you can kind of
you know you can go through it so many
times and you're kind of painting
yourself out of the room essentially
yeah and you look back and like well I
approve all those messages right now so
I better just leave at this point right
now it's for me it's when I'm in the
booth like when it goes to the mastering
lab you know I mean I'll go back I want
to change this line after we've already
recorded a song and everybody's parts on
it and you know it's a very last minute
for me the songs not and still sometimes
after that there's some lyrics I changed
live now you know because I still can't
I mean I can't change the one on the
record but yeah I can sing it
differently every night if I think of a
better way to word something you know
damn right I'm gonna sing it that way
and maybe they'll forget about the first
one right now I'm I finished the book
and I'm in that sort of in-between
region so and I guess you saw our two
year does so how does that you know
these these last three albums have just
you know kind of been incredibly popular
and beloved everything how does your
mind work when it starts to contemplate
the next thing I mean is there like I
guess I'm thinking specifically about is
there some kind of feeling like there's
something yet to be done or there's
something I haven't done to my own
satisfaction or is it like how does that
work yeah there's definitely space
there's there's definitely things that I
like to hear that I've not done yet you
know and there are types of music that I
listen to that I've never even attempted
to create and
you know a lot of that is me using the
devices that I've given myself to work
with the pressure rather than allow it
to make me anxious you know and and that
for the last two records I really had to
do because southeastern was done and
people reacted really really well to it
and it sold better than anything that
worked on in the past all right well if
that's as far as it goes then that's
great I can make a living off this play
some theaters we riding a bus for a
while it's gonna be gonna be awesome and
then when that happened again with the
record after that I caught myself going
oh [ __ ] what am I gonna do you know cuz
everybody's gonna expect that this is
just how my records are gonna be for the
rest of my life but um something kicked
in that told me that that's how it's
supposed to be I think gratitude kicked
in you know which is usually what helps
me out of any of those situations and it
was like no no you have been given a lot
here and and yes that's all there is to
it fine but that's not even a question
where it's asking the question worth
asking is how do you take advantage of
it and actually say things to people
that mean something to them now that you
have the microphone you know now that
you said something smart enough for them
to hand you the mic you have an
opportunity rather than pressure you
know yeah because I mean you know I
could live with being forgotten you know
that's not a big deal to me but what I
couldn't live with is thinking that I
had this I had this platform and didn't
use it to really you know explain myself
definitely mines me look at when we
start talking about your grandfather and
it sounded like he the way that he the
tradition out of which the music came
and the way he approached it was sort of
like making a reverence like a like
music is something to be reverent about
yes and so now it sounds like you're
maintaining that idea that now that
you've been given success and people so
loved your music that the functional
response is to say it's still our space
of reverence you know I'm not gonna like
degrade that or let that out of my sight
right and I'm not I never I'm very very
determined and never use it for any
purpose other than you know the the
actual creative artistic purpose of
making it because it needs to exist and
because it makes me happy and because it
makes other people feel like they're not
alone I've heard you talk about this
distinction between entertainer and
artist is that can you talk a little bit
about the what is arts supposed to do
and maybe especially at a time like ours
which is a little nutty do you first of
all is it is it other than academic to
ask yourself that question what is our
to and if it is other than academic what
do you think that's that's a tough one
you know I didn't I didn't consider
myself an artist for a long time because
I think I was thinking of it as you know
art is just really really good
entertainment you know and it's like
when you get really good entertaining
people all of a sudden you're an artist
but that's not exactly true I don't
think I feel like I feel like art exists
because it is needed you know and I
think I think a lot of it has to do with
how you aim the work that you're doing
if you don't aim it at all if you're
just you know if you're throwing
chickens out the window then I think in
some ways you're making art because if
it's more important to you to say
something even if that's something is
convoluted and hard to understand than
it is to attract something or to sell
something then I think you might be
making art yeah and I like to say
they're saying something because it's
you need to say it and I also feel too
that for me there was a big jump when I
said I need to say it but also I need to
include the listener in that
communication right in a non
condescending maybe even loving way
where although I'm saying it I'm also
saying it to kind of appeal to the
higher part of that person or to you
know to not not condescend to her at all
right which is which di is very is very
judgmental in it in and of itself I
think you know I think it is it's
narcissistic okay but what's an artist
if not narcissistic you know
and I think a lot of us spend their
whole lives like like trying to pay for
that yeah trying to pay off that debt
and and you know all the times that we
thought well I'm to be allowed to do
something great which when you say it
out loud it sounds absolutely ridiculous
but you know you've done something great
and you know some people would say that
I've done something great at some point
or another and so once that happens then
you think well you know how justified
was my thinking before and you know what
can I do to to you know leave only
footprints so to speak you know what can
I do to kind of fill back up the extra
water that I took you know my students
sometimes it you know at least in
fiction there's kind of a little bit of
an aversion to the entertainment or the
yeah the entertainment idea and I always
feel like if a person has ambition which
I certainly I'd comical comically high
levels and you know late to like
embarrassing to think about but if you
have it you know you guys are gonna
spend a lot of energy to nine and
suppressing it or gonna say alright I
accept you come on let's go have some
fun together and then you can purify
that intention as you're talking about
you know by being grateful and and
aspiring to higher thing but if you deny
it then you're just kind of like you
know it's like you had true love and you
didn't show up
totally totally and I'm sure you
probably had points in your life where
you felt like this is a moment when I
have to rise to the occasion yes you
know and I've had a lot of those and you
know I have a most night on stage that's
kind of kind of a long series of that
what a great opportunity because I don't
get those moments I tend to kind of just
bump along the bottom and to be sort of
held to your best self as Ritz it's you
know
it's really good for for a certain part
of you you know if you don't get if you
don't get bored by the gifts you know if
you if you work hard to keep yourself
from ever getting too used to it
I think that's that's the huge thing for
you know a performing artist is it's
very very easy to get used to it and
think that you're owed that and think
that because you've made great art you
know even if it is great art you know
which is probably not for the Creator to
say but even if you feel like you've
done something that goes to that next
level
you still aren't you aren't allowed to
it's not a right you know it's not just
because you made thing X doesn't mean
you deserve oh yeah making a mistake of
thinking that those gifts were self
created of course completely self
created and that's the problem I think
that's the problem that we're dealing
with more than anything else right now
is you know the American Dream gives
people an idea that the bottom that they
started from was the very bottom and the
absolute bottom and it's so important as
a as an American to feel like you earned
what you have yeah you know and that to
me is very very dangerous very dangerous
because I was I was reading something
you'd said about you know traveling to
parts of Asia
I think Singapore where you know you
said you saw what really what it was
really like for somebody to be poor and
to have no other options
you know and and now in this country we
have so many people who think that you
know legal naturalization is an option
for everybody you know they don't
understand how you could be in a place
where you cannot legally become an
American you know or how you could be in
a place where you can't leave Houston
before the hurricane is it just does it
to them that will happen
yeah I've been poor so I you know so I
could have done it right but that that
that American idea that says that makes
that weird connection between good luck
and individual virtue you know you're
born a certain way with certain gifts
and you forget that you sort of just
came out of heaven that way you know
yeah and you yeah you forget about that
time you won the lottery that's
how did you forget about winning the law
I want it because I you know I've heard
people say well at least I played early
you know that was my yeah are they are
there I'm thinking about this are there
songs that you well first of all does
your faith in the power of music ever
wane
you know for example you wake up and the
idea of music is a little stale or it
isn't speaking to you it always beats
you it does and I don't listen to as
much music as a lot of my peers I don't
you know my wife listens to way more and
so I that's something I have to work to
do you know and last week I bought like
five or six Records and I you know I
work hard to stay current my wife is
very important to know what's happening
after the question offered yesterday
yeah but are there songs that in your
from your past that you turn to to like
it s that's that's a good song
you know or the ones I've read yeah
alright well that and also others like
benchmarks that you would kind of every
soften go back and look at and go okay
this is this is first a lot but for you
know for you what we're at what are your
three favorites of yours
am i yeah as of right now like this I
think elephant is probably my best song
probably my best song but vampires on
the new record it's that good - I think
I think they're pretty pretty even as
far as you know I can't find any fat
although my and you better sound like
that and you come back and listen to it
or does it feel like you did it or is
there sense like wow that not really
yeah you're right it's kind of like I
mean I could I wept you know we're both
of those with the empire's I couldn't
sing it to my wife to show it to her I
just had to stop and wait ten minutes
and start over and stop again and in the
studio you know I choked up you know and
yeah that seems to me I was embarrassed
by that whole scene because it's like
what an awful thing to be you know this
moved by something that you just made up
but that's the same time it was
everything that went into it and it was
that feeling of you know that conduit
thing that songwriters talk about
sometimes and it's it's true I don't
want it to be true I want it to all be
because you know I sit there and work
really hard but that one didn't take
very long
at all you know it's just you're holding
on you know and and I saw him I wrote
called dress blues years ago which is
not a very lyrically mature you know the
craft of the song is not where I am
right now but I wrote it in the time it
took to write it down on a piece of
paper and you know it was another one of
those that I just broke down when I was
done with it because it was about
somebody that I knew you know something
then it actually happened and and I just
felt like I was hanging on and just
trying to get it out before it went on
to the next station because you know I
haven't had the feeling that one of the
reasons we get so addicted to this
creative stuff is that it frees us well
frees me temporarily from this guy you
know you're in the throes of process
somehow you get access to something that
must be you but it's also not you and
for me that's the most wonderful thing
is when you find that you're better than
this person and then that thing goes out
and connects with a part of the audience
that also is better than they are
undated yeah so it makes sense me that
you could write a song and and move
yourself with it because you're not
actually writing it it's some other
right yeah yeah you've accessed
something that you don't live with you
know something that you're not in
connecting in close quarters with all
day it's something you're not tired of
yet some part of you that doesn't reveal
itself enough for you to be irritated by
that's a dream yeah it's like your
nephews or something you know oh I'm so
happy to see you you know I don't have
to clean up after you right what are the
top three guitar solos in your personal
life account of other people that like
that okay and what makes a good one I
guess that's well I think the stairway
to heaven outro is pretty hard to beat
I think Hendrix all along the watchtower
so I was as you know something that just
nobody had ever heard anything like that
before
and I really loved David Lindley slap
steal playing I like his fiddle playing
too but I think what do you did on
running on empty the Jackson Browne song
I think that little snippet is you know
as far as spontaneous musical creation
is really
really really good it's--there's wit
about it and you know I think I think a
solo that you're improvising you know
you have to rely on you have to be
really thinking on your feet and and you
have to it's almost like a chess match
because you have to see steps ahead
while you're playing you have to see a
way out
that makes sense that bookends you know
and are you thinking melodically or sort
of in shapes you know I'm a lot aquatic
yeah yeah melodically usually singing in
my head or I'm actually sometimes I
actually singing it you know I think
that's a really good thing for musicians
who are improvising is to sing along
with what you're playing while you're
improvising because that steers you more
out of the physical and into the you
know emotional into the melodic world
rather than looking at where your hands
are falling on the instrument let me
jump to something else we I think we
both come from places where they're
probably skewed Trump in the in the last
election so can you give me your I mean
this is the totally [ __ ] question
unfair but what is your sense of what's
going on in our country in the last you
know whatever 300 years well I don't I
don't I don't think we've looked in the
closet quite enough you know III think I
think the fact that we've avoided
conversations for so long is catching up
to us now that those conversations are
unavoidable since we're all in such
close contact because of cell phones and
the internet and social media we're
being forced to talk about things that
we should have talked about 50 60 70 a
hundred years ago that makes me happy
I'm glad to see the conversations
finally finally happening
but it's kind of like having an
intervention with somebody you know
that's been an addict for 15 years it's
like I should have done this would have
been way easier if you had done it 10
years ago you know I'm just not
convinced that our country elected
Donald Trump president I'm still not
convinced
I've not seen definitive evidence yet
did that happened
you know without some sort of outside
influence and you know III think that
probably a lot of people don't put their
money where their mouth is and a lot of
people say one thing and vote another
way and and I think a lot of people more
than I assumed a lot of people feel like
the system doesn't represent them so
they were ready for anything other than
the system now that I could understand
if it didn't include sexism and racism
and you know a general disregard for
anybody who's not you know white and
male but when you throw those things and
I don't feel sorry for anybody who felt
excluded and voted that way now because
you know they should have they should
have outgrown those things I feel sorry
for a two-year-old who uses the n-word
but you know not for a 20 year old or a
30 year old or a 40 year old that's kind
of feeling there's a yeah that Lincoln
book had so much civil war stuff in it
and I finished it before the election
and thought oh in some ways we've never
concluded this civil war and then like
yeah we really didn't now we hope you're
sure it's true yeah I love your song
white man's world a there's a really
beautiful idea that it's not the line
I'll probably misquote it but the no war
is what no such thing as someone else
yeah and I think that for me you know
I've been thinking about this stuff a
lot and thinking that the you know I
mean racism as a as a white person's sin
in our country and that those of us who
may be stupidly thought that that was
all in the past I feel like for me now
it's the time to really start thinking
about it and trying to explain to any
trace of it and and be a leader in that
way instead of you someone says oh yeah
I definitely think racism sucks but an
aggressive advocate of the opposite
which is such an American idea that we
really believe we're all equal and we're
really gonna live that way yeah that
seems to be I mean I don't know if
that's what the founding fathers had in
mind but that's what I always grew up
thinking that's what there's a yeah yeah
and yeah I know some of them definitely
did not
but what American has always meant to me
was that was that you know the dream is
available to us all
and you know like like none of us are
free you know like that song who I don't
know who was originally responsible for
that maybe Curtis Mayfield but you know
I know he did if there's a hell below
we're all gonna go but I think none of
us are free might might have predated
that but if one of us has chained none
of us are free and you know to me I
think I think that inclusion you know
helps everything when you realize that
you know this is this is our fault you
know and of course my family didn't own
slaves they were pretty broke but
doesn't matter it doesn't matter and and
I think people have a hard time why
people who believe that racism can work
both ways don't understand the
connection with power they don't
understand that you have to be in a
place of power to really be racist in a
systematic way it's not just about you
know some angry kid calling you a
cracker or a white boy you know it's you
have to be able to exert force in some
way or another on the person that you're
in elephant sitting is yeah yes yes you
know mouse sitting on an elf and it's
not the same as an elephant sitting yes
but I'm a mouse right yeah so so do you
have a sense of what's next I mean
you're touring out but are there songs
being written our forming Laura there
are songs forming yeah um I'm always
taking notes and you know writing little
riffs on the guitar and and then when I
go into the process when I get a
deadline set for myself thank goodness I
have the label and nobody's breathing
down my neck and you know I'm a
publishing now and all that stuff so
when I get you know in my mind and I
want to make a record and set a deadline
I'll I'll go through all the notes and
I'll really dig in you know start
spending five or six hours a day or more
you know working and this part I don't
consider to be working the touring you
know it's the traveling is not easy but
it's a lot easier than it used to be
because sometimes I did 200 shows in a
van in a year
and yeah that's brutal for you when you
go to play over here is it a rush I mean
it's every night is yeah definitely
there's a dren illan every time I go out
and if there's not I think what have I
done wrong today that sleep last night
or what you know because people you know
the people I know who are who love your
music they really love it I mean it's
it's not just like oh yeah I really like
his song but they those songs really
speak to them in a deep you must feel
that yeah I I do I'm very grateful for
that and I feel like that's because I
didn't set out to make music that was
being consumed while you were doing
something else you know because a lot of
music is for that and and there's a
place for it you know I love you know
bubblegum pop music sometimes if it's
done the right way most my favorite pop
music is ESL what I call ESL pop English
has said yeah because I think that that
really they don't the way the English
language comes across for somebody who's
not from you know the US or the UK is
very interesting to me and a pop song I
think it just makes for better lyrics
because they don't quite they're not
trying to mean as much now that's just
in pop music but back to my point is I I
really try very hard to make music that
is supposed to be listened to while you
are listening to music you know maybe
you're driving a car maybe you're
jogging but you're not socializing with
anything other than the song and you're
not you know grilling out hanging out
with your friends and talking while
elephant plays in the background it's
not more than you know people say sad
they say it's sad and that's just drives
me crazy the two things that drive me
the craziest about you know people's
attitudes towards the music that I make
are it's sad you know meaning it's
moving you know it's not just sad you
know mornings are mornings are sad and
and they're funny and then life is sad
and it's also all this other [ __ ] but
it's sad and also when they assume that
every first person narrator is me yeah
and that is so frustrating but I
I find really sad as a song or a piece
of art that doesn't engage with the
whole range of things we write on a
propagandistic or or that kind of
American thing or you like don't take it
so serious you know yeah yeah if you
could look back at the song the
songwriter you were at 20 or 21 what
will you say to him or I guess I really
want to know is how is your aesthetic
sense changed since then what do you
value now that you didn't value then or
vice versa I do more editing now that's
for sure the time must been editing has
grown over the years a lot um that's a
hard one that's a hard one for me
because I feel like I'm in such a really
good place now creatively and personally
that you know I wouldn't want to jinx
that yeah I would just not even plus I
also wouldn't want to have a
conversation with that ass no he
wouldn't listen that's funny to me how
much of the process that one goes
through after something is done where
you talk about it sometimes in the
middle of talking about I'm like that is
[ __ ] that is not actually your I'm
right now I'm saying something that is
theoretically true but in the actual
practice it's not yeah yeah I do that
catch myself and yeah in reality I just
it's just it's one big thing you know
and if that process wasn't what it was
this process wouldn't be what it is you
know and I I was not in a hurry to get
to my peak you know and I'm not now in a
hurry to get better I mean I want you
know what I mean I want to get better
but I want I know what it takes to get
better and I know that it takes that
amount of time of really refining why do
I like this and why is this necessary
and I go back and I play a lot of those
songs steal you know a couple of them a
night that I wrote when I was 21 or 22
and for the most part I think they're
they're good you know I can still sing
them without cringing and
okay and they rock sometimes more than
they have more energy maybe than what I
have right now but I think you know try
to be probably more empathetic that's
that's it you know just try to try to
see other perspectives other than the
one of the of the the narrator the point
you're trying to drive home in these
songs you know because I look back at
the song like outfit which I wrote for
the drive-by truckers and that song
meant a lot to a lot of drive-by
truckers fans and a lot of people who
have close relationships with their
father but now I look back on it now I
think there's something about that said
that's a little bit exclusive that's a
little bit you know I was trying to get
across my dad's personality and I in a
humor humorous way and you know it could
have even come across as being a little
bit homophobic at someone and for the
longest time I met it never occurred to
me and then like Terry Gross asked me
something about it and I was like oh
[ __ ] Terry Gross Terry Gross knows
what's up and I'm in trouble you know
you got to watch out for the Terry
grosses of the world there's one of them
but it's funny how when you get today so
you know what's in the middle or at some
point you and your writing you look back
and you see it it's almost like a books
that are a little bit wonky on the Shelf
like they're not all straight and maybe
if you want it back to straighten them
up they lose some essential energy yeah
I think so it sounds like you have a lot
of faith in the kind of I always call it
the subconscious maybe that's the wrong
term but that kind of thing that you
don't have control over but it seems to
be pretty smart and it seems to be bent
on progressing somehow and then you know
I feel like if I just honor that by
showing up to work every day that thing
is smarter than me and it kind of leads
you a little bit I mean yeah and it
might cause some mistakes but in the end
it causes growth whether you want or not
and all you have to do is sort of honor
it by not forgetting it's there and that
you have to service it through labor or
something like that yeah I think so like
the muse likes to find you working right
but also you know I've gotten better at
shifting between that and the front the
frontal lobe you know and I think that's
a big part of what the editing process
is figuring out how to get in and out of
that coat right you know put that suit
on very quickly go back and forth
between
the suit that you don't necessarily have
control over and the suit that you do
that's because it's totally fine today
we're both suits are both you and
they're completely yeah yeah yeah as
long as you know long as you don't
ignore either one of them and you know
keep them in good shape and they'll
they'll both fit forever you know but it
is that I think sometimes when I'm
writing I think okay now it's time to
shift into the other gear and fix this
yeah your lyrics are incredible to other
poets that you read
are you a reader poetry yeah not as much
as far as like current poets I was a big
fan of mark strand and you know Louise
Glick and and one of the things I read
in college I continued reading afterward
and you know I with the two-year-old and
the touring schedule and it's about all
I can do to get to the fiction and I
really enjoy a whole lot you know and I
went through a period there I think
Jennifer Egan hit me in a way that just
really made me have the closest I've
ever had to a panic attack I was on a
plane reading a visit from the goon
squad and it just hit some part of me so
hard that it was almost like being on
LSD or something I had the same thing on
a plane with David Foster Wallace's
oblivion and I realized it was hitting
me a really agitated and not altogether
Pleasant way yeah with Darien played
made me nauseated now you know I felt
myself like break into a kind of a cold
sweat truth sucks the truth does suck
and I I felt like I couldn't lose him
with what I was like I was getting
judged by something that I could not
make excuses to this she had a new and
I'll call Manhattan Beach this that
reading gallery and it was really great
everything pretty much everything I've
read of hers I've just really loved even
the the story that she did in like tweet
yes yeah that was so good but you know I
like Peter Madison's work a lot Dennis
Johnson I think was did you write
fiction are you tempted in that first I
am tempted and I have tried
I don't like it you know I just don't
like it and when I start writing a song
within a few minutes I can find
something that makes me happy something
that's the reward of you've just written
a good line but with fiction I can't I
can't do that huh
I know it's a matter of something that I
should just work through and at some
point I think I will do that and keep
working and try to write a page a day
for a year and then figure it out and
try to find a good editor and all that
kind of stuff but right now I can't get
to that release you know I can't get
that like serotonin shot oh right
you just did an awesome ROM keep going
right I have a theory this may not be
right but I feel like I've talked to a
lot of people about this and there's a
moment in your young life when you make
a stand for some art form you know where
you go okay I've got to be all in on
this I'm not gonna be who I want to be
and I think it's for me that was pros I
used to play guitar and stuff I never
could get any decisiveness about it like
yeah that's kind of good but with pros I
always knew what I believed in and that
resulted in this serotonin shot if you
see something that you wrote that sucks
and if you fix it and then you get that
little little thing so yeah it's seems
like so much of what we do has to do
with that split second visceral reaction
I love it I hate it and then and then
also that authority of knowing what to
do next to make it better or something
like that oh yeah yeah yeah that yeah
knowing where where to go also on you
know sometimes and I know this happens
as a musician and I'm not sure if it
happens in other types of writing too
but I feel like over time you start
figuring out what mistakes could be
followed and and what mistakes could
wind up giving you a voice that you know
well maybe not unique is still something
that belongs yeah to you you know cuz
like I go back and listen to like for
example there's a there's a Wurlitzer
piano
there and if we were to plug it up and
play it it would sound absolutely
nothing like a piano you know but the
intention was to recreate an acoustic
piano in a small portable unit the sound
it makes is you know probably just as
good and and and really very very useful
in popular music rock and roll music
sometimes it's better than a piano for
that but it's not anything like what
they were shooting for you know and I
listen the Rolling Stones and I think
you know they were just trying to be
black American blues musicians and they
missed you know splendidly yeah and and
then they kept missing in the same way
they it's almost like they knew that's
the mistake to follow so you're saying
it sometimes in the process you aim for
perfection you don't get it but then by
acknowledging it and then using that it
becomes a different kind of process
right yeah right and I think that's I
think I'm kind of trying to ask you that
question because when I read your work I
get this like I feel like I get a sense
of who you are but also I think it's
kind of impossible that you could have
that many interests because sometimes I
read something like simply a girl
diaries that seems like science fiction
in a way but then it extends so far
beyond that you know and and a lot of
the stories in that in that collection
we're that way to me it's like how could
you possibly have the time and minee
different interests that all seem to
tell me what how you view the world how
you see your it is right because all
those things start off to be something
else and I [ __ ] them up yeah and then
instead of denying them I go okay all
right and you figure out what yeah in in
fiction what you do is you I mean I you
rework at so many times that it starts
to teach you its own logic and those
early it's like um I guess maybe like if
a diamond was forming there was a turd
in it
you know that the diamond would form
around the turd yeah and if it formed
enough you'd forget that there was a
turd in it that might not be the most
graceful right but no but yeah but in a
certain way that I think that's the
the confidence you were talking about to
follow the mistake because how else are
to do something and I'm like oh this
would be such a nice story about X and
then I drop it and it shatters and it's
a big mess and at that's step I think
when I was younger I'd say okay I gotta
start over or go to law school or
something but now I'm like okay you made
a mistake but a mistake is only a
mistake if you don't acknowledge it and
except I and write bill on with it yeah
like Duane Allman playing the wrong note
again right that's what he would say you
know it's never no it's the one right
after it that's right or wrong right if
you play the wrong note just play it
again yeah and then see where that goes
and you know you're always a half a step
away from the right knows you'll find
and you insist on it a few more times
then yeah yeah it becomes a right note I
love talking to you thank you so much I
have loved that too and I tell you like
with the Lincoln and the Bardo I can't
even describe that book to people
without getting emotional like trying to
tell people what the [ __ ] book is
about it's hard for me but it was such a
beautiful story is tweet about it oh
good good well I loved it I'm glad it's
having success because it's a great book
onward onward
thank you enjoyed it
[Music]
and then right here it's got the tattoo
that my wife and I got on her 30th
birthday in New Zealand really funny
clever needed
[Music]